our series pushing the limits is
focusing on the children of 9/11 heroes
for among the newest members of the New
York City Fire Department the FDNY swore
in 301 new probationary firefighters at
a ceremony yesterday that included a
record number of legacies whose fathers
died protecting New Yorkers 13 of the
new firefighters lost a parent during
the 9/11 attacks
Lola lanky visited the FDNY fire academy
and smoke spoke with six of the brave
recruits honoring a heroic legacy since
I was little I always wanted to do this
for Leonard and Anthony regalia becoming
firefighters has been a lifetime in the
making the brothers are part of FDNY's
newest graduating class but to them it's
not just a job it's a way of life I
really want to be like that helping so
many different people you know and FDNY
ran in the family the regalia say their
passion for helping others stems from
their father Leonard J regalia who was
also a New York City firefighter just
like Manny Moe he his dad
Manuel Malika growing up my father was a
super hero to me it's a family legacy a
proud but painful one September 11th
this year was definitely different for
me oh it gave me a different outlook on
it you know now going through the
training and understanding the child it
gives a little sense of clarity that I
didn't really have growing up how old
were you guys when you knowing 9/11 I
was ten I was seven I was mark and
Rebecca's sorrows father
Carla sorrow was a 39 year old FDNY
firefighter when he died on 9/11 I
remember the morning those the last time
I saw him he came my room in Bali early
morning to go to work and he brought me
tic tacs and then I went off to school
kids were getting pulled home
one by one no one really knew it was
going on I kept ask my mom when my
father was coming home she didn't have
an answer they never found him
the guys from fires were stepping up and
just always there whatever we needed and
I just continued for years it's not a to
be a part of that now you know knowing
that people rely on us Thomas he Dalls
father Dennis he Dalls senior died in
2015 from cancer he developed while
sifting through Ground Zero rubble the
books are written in blood and one of
the biggest events happen it definitely
makes you think about it and stuff
especially the guys here lost I fought
the day of you know it's serious stuff
you guys know better than anyone the
risks and the dangers involved in in
this line of work but you choose to do
it anyway why I think you know my father
gave his life for this job you know and
somebody other people did and it's just
it's a very rewarding job being anything
else was like my dad and being just like
him certainly and definitely outweighs
the dangers and risks of the job some
might feel bound by their legacy but
these firefighters seem emboldened by
bears what's it mean to wear that FDNY
in your chest then it means everything
to me know these four letters you know
hopefully will guide me to the rest of
my life all of the legacies we spoke to
say despite some nervous mom's guys
their families are 100% supported behind
their decision to join the FDNY yeah but
their fathers would be so proud of just
watching them know what it means
the 9/11 legacy and them continuing the
legacy that's right yeah well done Nolan
angey get the table